okay well for people who are joining
this livestream this is a design review
of features of wolf Natha related to
food so in the nutrition compass why do
we change the the week do we have people
from design on this coal by the way
think so are we talking about design
partially but today they have seen most
of it I think okay so what's the before
and after here so this is you must do
what yeah yeah so um based on our
previous meetings that we've had we
changed some things to put in the scale
the scale is probably the most notable
change from before and after as you can
see there um I like the scale now what
what how do you how is it indicating I
don't understand
20% FTA which one is I don't understand
why is not I noticed and why doesn't
that just say zero percent ten percent
twenty percent and then FD adv at the
end if that's what those are and then it
doesn't even need to say actual right
you see what I'm saying yeah we can get
rid of that then yeah that's a good
point
yeah the percent probably should be on
there to save a little bit space and not
have the latest short as possible yes
but I think it takes up more space if we
have that legend there so yeah probably
getting rid of the legend would be
preferable um yeah I think you should go
to the legend and say zero percent ten
percent twenty percent and then after
the twenty percent so I have to FD adv
yeah sounds good okay that's nice looks
nice actually
what's that that does not look like a
beautiful it will look better when it's
actually in regular Wolfram language
right now because it's in development it
has that okay I don't put that
formatting so okay all the numbers of
nutrients okay so we go Pentagon we go
whatever we go you know basically this
is just to get an idea of what where the
angles are mod these were most of them
were designed specified and so I just
wanted to show you what they look like
again we'll put in the percents and that
sort of thing - there's 2% and yeah just
a percentage sign isn't gonna hurt it
probably I mean if you really we could
also move it to the bottom only in cases
like that and then it might look a
little better like the triangle case for
example if you see that that could be a
little easier to read yes
well then you have to you have to
rearrange the things so they're always a
flat bottom piece that could be done I
wouldn't yeah I mean again you could run
that one across that and you just have
to make a decision on which of the sides
to bring it out of I mean right right
lower I would say not kind of in Libya
there so I agree I agree yeah this is in
comprehensible because it doesn't you
know it's not clear what the gray or
there's a lot of gray lines there um
okay three buttons what is this
so we had discussed some zooming feature
to be able to zoom in and zoom out in
order to see small numbers more clearly
like for example this one here the
maximum is a little less than 30%
but it might be nice to see what 100%
looks like for example and so design
suggested that we put something in like
that but I don't think that's really a
good plan because we had previously
talked about putting in a more button to
be able to add more nutrients assuming
we could do it would change the scale so
that down my would effectively consume
don't think it's worth it I don't think
it's necessary okay sure then yeah we
don't have to worry about three buttons
then as you can see the suggestions that
we have groups here basic nutrients
vitamins and minerals and actually we
could put in another one for fats and
herbs together but the only reason why
they have to be together is because
there's not enough for them because we
can only make the triangle shape really
it yeah I was done find to me basic
nutrients fats and carbs fit immense
minerals cannot cannot make their own
plot anymore what do you mean what kind
of their own plot show me fat protein
and no no they can't through energy
value this is alpha for only I mean it's
one short you don't get all the
convenience to pork up what you want
okay and I think we can work out am an
open code button or something like that
to be able to show that better yeah
that's a good idea I mean you could even
have an interactive thing why not you
can have an interactive component that
will be relevant for outside no I mean
an interactive element yes in what will
be the future cloud Wolfram Alpha
yeah yeah that'd be good yeah
okay physical-activity pod good I'm glad
you had some ridiculous um level of
precision right yes it's true we've
right but it takes seven hours of sleep
to sleep off a Big Mac according to the
data that we have in physical activity
yeah we actually fixed a bug with the
fat one the fat one is in terms was in
terms of pounds and so the numbers were
a little off and now it's it's been
fixed um so what you're seeing there is
is indeed correct I was proposing 50%
working we should at work on language
programming is activity yes
unfortunately the data for that is not
much different than um be sitting one I
believe that's that's the point it
depends on the mental mental how much
the brain dissipate fifty watts or
something yeah but it dissipates it
anyway whatever that's that's really
true I mean you know clearly people who
have PET scanners and things right and
they you know that they're detecting
some additional glucose they're
detecting where the brain is
metabolizing glucose I just don't know
whether the aggregate is significant on
the overall scale I have no opinion
about this is this sorted by order of
how long is this is this a fixed
sequence or is this sorted by its it's
sorted by a time it goes from shortest
to longest okay first at the top longest
at the bottom and in the cases of ranges
I sort them by the the mean of the two
end points okay again we're gonna be
hooking this up so that it'll work for
other quantities and a little footnote
at the bottom will say what it's for one
feature that Michael suggested was
removing an entire
column if they're all less than
threshold which currently is one minute
I think that may be useful and and the
way we're doing Les Deux that what we
say if we remove them all just the whole
column so that way the calories one
would probably still show stuff but the
the fat one
would maybe not I don't see what's the
problem I mean because because basically
it's just saying it's a nominal amount
right you can't keep it I I would say to
keep it because I mean otherwise people
will be confused oh is that you know
it's gonna take me forever to burn off
the fat for that yeah that's a good
point so for now with the bar charts I
know one of the complaints that you had
before was that the bars were too thick
and so to make it thinner right now
right and I just need to do some more
tweaks on how this is done to make it
look this way they didn't like that I
was using a spectra here to control it
it depends on the number of bars I'm
thinking that yeah it's okay percent day
value I'm thinking I was thinking you
might want to put the percentage signs
on that but but but I guess not it's not
necessary this is fine okay yeah okay
and of course the input interpretation I
haven't had that much time to look at it
too much one last time I think we more
or less agreed on the lowest level boxes
which I believe have been implemented
here should be most of the upper ones in
this example in this examples grid but
the wood item why is it in the smaller
font to such just a bug I think that's
just the default there but we can make
it the same size well I don't know what
the I mean yeah I just looks odd again
some of the formatting may not be unit
it it's it's accounting unit no I
understand
I understand but is it really wise it's
smaller than these I mean it's just
there's something odd and the spacing is
wrong
so on so right now these are from my
local implementation of it this is not
going to look better on the server
actually yeah I think so too I think
you're right I think once it's actually
fully integrated in properly it will
look much better this is just kind of a
sandbox so to speak I don't think that
gutter is useful to us
I think it just looks kind of weird okay
um I think there is a certain argument
to put a small amount of grey behind
these things or to somehow distinguish
them from the right-hand side are they
and slightly in grey yes they should
no I don't think we agreed to do that on
those sorry I got confused at the
property case which is below I think we
should do the slightly gray because I
think with their annotations I mean you
could just read chicken-fried leg
without reading that it's a preparation
fried so I would go slightly gray maybe
just 20 percent cry something like that
sure we can look into that yeah but only
in this case we have to be cave on on
the left or in all cases
no I'm saying and the these ones don't
have a gutter I mean this is the gutter
I'm talking about is perfect inside that
okay so it's so just to make sure that I
understand properly view the area that
says amount the area that says food type
preparation and food part those would
have a slightly gray background no it
was my first thought but I think that's
wrong I think the correct thing is that
the woods would be slightly great I
think they are if you want them more
gray we can make them more gray maybe 10
percent more gray sure
okay this heavy bar is not something
we've done in other places it reminds me
awfully of a nutrition label I think
it's okay anybody else okay with it I
think so because it's it's alright okay
I mean we could do that by indicating it
with some color background or something
I think this is probably okay all right
okay what's this case here I go okay
that's why you need those gutters yes or
at least in this case we would probably
need the gutters so this is the list
case of all of them again for these
groupings of things we did not really
come up with a good solution for a lot
of it mostly we just wanted to take a
look at it again and see if you know
what I think you can just get rid of
those two separator lines you've just
happened three floating boxes right yeah
I mean I'm not sure whether they do they
need a plus sign between them but that's
different yeah the addition cases is
different oh I see what is this case is
this case this case is a comparison or a
list of them let's do well of comparison
it's the same thing what do we do with
other comparisons normally they're not
the bacon reusable to get balls on
depends I see
why don't we do that here they could be
awfully big I think the concern was last
time if you did for example we want to
stack them all vertically I mean why not
use some of the horizontal space as well
I think we were worried about how much
verticals or rather horizontal space
they would take up but I don't mind
doing that the issue is not I guess
there isn't too much of an issue to that
except for it being very long so we
could I think usually what's done is row
where the separator is a is a vertical
bar so I would try I mean but what do
you get to you know triple quadruple
deca whatever
yeah and also it may not format the best
in the world because of the wrapping but
maybe it's not so bad okay
well I'm not sure which wrapping I mean
this is the wrapping of these macro
blocks basically yes if imagine if each
of those rocks of those boxes was in row
with a separator for with the separator
being just vertical bar yeah then yeah
I'd probably work okay in this case but
if I think the political boss separators
it's gonna look silly
okay I think that's the default behavior
for most other no I understand one of
the questions whether separate about as
a as a spanning character or not yeah
and I'm not sure and usually it isn't
usually it's a fixed type but here maybe
it'd be better if is a spanning
character I'm not sure maybe that would
look stupid too or maybe we should have
commas of some kind or maybe nothing as
the separators I think you need to show
some some of the bad cases sure multi
Decker many things wrapping poorly or we
use this small the decay versus obvious
it's fine if that's what it's going to
be I don't think that's bad I'm sorry I
didn't catch that one vs yes yeah I
think I showed that before and I don't
think anyone was really happy about that
discussion if it's Benz doesn't even
come up if what nobody would expect it
to spend so we don't have one of the
problems you might yes I think we've got
to see some cases but I think the vs
thing will be okay why is this always
stacking vertically again same behavior
that's just the idea we had but we can
we can make that okay this is fine I
think this is fine and this is this is
particularly if they get really
complicated and I think here obviously
it doesn't need to have Gaza because of
the way the pluses work and looks good
sure so so in general in the plus case
it's fine to have it like that
I think so okay
I mean I'd like to see some more cases I
think you might want to go a little bit
gray on the plus sign sure that can be
done I don't know maybe it's better to
stack it I don't know even in this case
if you stack it just forget the outer
border and just have that vertical that
horizontal separator that would probably
look fairly reasonable sure okay yeah I
think you're right I think that would
make it a little easier to see and then
that's consistent with this case here
where you've got a box that's extruded
from the protein content so to speak and
then you've just got a horizontal
separator here right yeah I agree that
makes sense okay now why does your
amount here you've got an amount but it
doesn't have the heavy separator I think
that's I think that's just a flaw in my
implementation but I will fix that okay
I think it's just because I was packing
it together real quick to show an
example so I know you'd ask to see more
examples but I didn't really have the
time to do that but I did get to look
into a little more of the distribution
how these things are all set up to
figure out whether we have enough room
and that sort of thing so the left-hand
sides the amount food type to
preparation that's this distribution
which is all more or less less than 15
characters will say object is how long
is preparation like 11 I want to say I
think 14 I had to do the same thing I'm
just yesterday
I loved it you were absolutely right
okay okay what about lies here what
you're gonna deal with the outlaws
yeah the outliers will be replaced with
with and without those are for
nutritional supplement and nutritional
not added those can be folded in with
the with and without as we've discussed
before so I think the left hand sides
are fine the right hand sides are a
little more tricky but I think we're
okay if we do the stacked case another
reason to keep the stacking is that um
there are some that are significantly
longer and so here the median as you can
see is mine beings about ten so it's
really not all that different than the
the left hand sides but some of them
spill over much longer and I think it's
from roughly looking at it it looks like
anything less than about say 25
characters should still nicely fit even
in the property case where it's very
wide
and if we're worried I guess we could
also stack the words calorie content and
that sort of thing I think the emergency
case is the case where it's like 35 long
and the only question is how's it going
to break and if it breaks upward
boundaries I think it'll probably be
okay it'll stack a little bit in the in
the right hand side there were I think
that's horrible okay let's go stack
there it's gonna say with you know
finest you know free range whatever free
range chocolate chips or something um I
don't think it will be disastrous if
that wraps to a second line sure and
that's just to show it in greater detail
for the individual ones which as you can
see most of them are dramatically less
than the AMA and the regime where it's
really potentially bad you should
probably look at some of those
manufacturers that may be goofed up I
mean that may be all kinds of things
that says you know bloody Blair is a
trademark of blah blah blah which is
it's not I know those super long
manufacturers look suspicious to me yeah
I agree yeah I was really surprised at
the length on those as well
well it might also be you know Blair
Blair division of blah blah blah
blah blah blah yeah that's that's
entirely possible yeah all right I think
the good news is about some of those is
that they have a lot of water breaks in
there and then we won't have to worry so
much about the AMA
yeah well I don't know that single words
that are super long I haven't gone into
that detail but that's a good question I
bet there aren't I bet it's going to be
okay baby
this might be what is it trimming level
that has to do with like fat trimming so
like an eighth of an inch fat less than
an eighth of an inch fat and quarter
inch things like that well it looks very
nice very nice all right so when they're
gonna go live as soon as we can I guess
I mean when are you going to have it on
on tests and so on do you say the small
number of weeks and you said months
conference okay terrific it's some okay
and we also put this speak posted and
readmit for the how it works with the
knowledge base for the tech conference
oh yeah yeah nice and yeah well this is
looking really good yep I think the
problems are solved I think we're good
to go here I just had a solicitation
today for some cooking in space thing
[Music]
not my scene I'm gonna I'm gonna
hopefully soon other Rockets too but
we'll see alright sounds good okay